ich habe ich im letzten jahr viel mit
kochen mit essen mit restaurants
beschäftigt aber ich habe mich noch nie
und wie sollte ich auch mit der zukunft
vom essen beschäftigt und darum geht es
heute wir waren auf der anuga der
weltgrößten lebensmittel
wirtschaftsmesse in köln und kann so
viel sagen es war unfassbar
eindrucksvoll wir haben unzählige stände
gesehen und es gab jede menge
kostenloses essen klingt nicht schlecht
viel spaß mit dem video und den
verrücktesten innovationen im
lebensmittelmarkt
[Musik]
freunde was geht und herzlich willkommen
zu diesem neuen video hier von der anuga
wir haben direkt hin dort etwas was mir
direkt ins auge gestochen ist wir sind
seit 20 minuten auf der messe nämlich
gefüllte waffe habe ich noch nie gesehen
und wir probieren jetzt weiter
bei den herren i
hate you dad ostern also man postet die
einfach kurz auch gefüllt mit schokolade
es gibt ganz viele verschiedene
füllungen habe ich selbst noch nie
vergessen und ich probiere jetzt mal
super knusprig geil flüssige schokolade
drin man kann kaum reden also sehr klebt
einem der mund guter start für mich
sagen schmeckt super und ich bin
gespannt was hört noch so erleben
ich kenne dieses großen eis nur von so
fans die ideen aus venedig oder so alle
drei entwürfe so leute vor sich
auspacken ja gerade erzählt daß man ich
weiß dieses produkt was jetzt esse kann
könnt ihr alle in zukunft irgendwie erst
im februar kaufen bereit also muss ich
sagen für so ein fertiges schon sehr
sehr hübsche sowie eine rose aufgebaut
kommt auch zum valentinstag raus
passenderweise das doch
sehr cremig ich weiß nicht ob es mir ein
bild aber so eine kleine mindestnote
ich habe mich unfassbar viel geschmack
muss man sagen aber eine geile
konsistenz auf jeden fall kriegt einen
daumen hoch so gehören ja noch was her
ach das ist ja hier gibt es pizza aber
nicht irgendwie sondern mit rote beete
boden mit spinat boden blumenkohl und
ist die sonne rote beete plätze hat
glaube ich von euch auch noch niemand
vergessen deshalb bin ich jetzt freier
nicht wo wir das mal für uns aus
[Musik]
hier haben wir sie also rote beete pizza
also um ehrlich zu sein weiß ich nicht
was ist davon erwarten nach aber dating
ist sehr lecker riecht auch schön noch
heute aber deswegen ist das natürlich
jetzt keine pc vergleichen können mit
einer pizza vom italiener zum einen weiß
hätten nichts mit mir zu tun und es ist
eine tiefkühlpizza aber ich will nicht
so schnell urteilen bei fragen mich ob
man die rote beete schmeckt der boden
ist zu 50 prozent auf großer beete und
ist jetzt schon relativ und möglich
diesen spagat für benutzer spricht dann
wurde gesagt super lecker
ich musste erstmal ob diese gesamte
pizza kreation klarkommen baltic
hurricanes ein vegetarisches checken der
rote beete bodenreform überraschend gut
also ist knusprig auf den ersten biss
aber auch selbst flog aber diese erdigen
geschmack von roter bete dass organisch
ich habe schon mal nachgeschaut bestimmt
haben doch schon welche von richters
probiert weil es gibt es schon
vereinzelt aber ich selbst kann es noch
nicht und
ab zur nächsten station sowie einen
stand gefunden der war bei den
innovationen ausgeschilderte kleine
testo kügelchen die tief gefroren sind
mit dem man irgendwie mit einem
paragraphen nur eine portion pasta
machen kann ich bin gespannt wird man
kann also hier sind so diese gefrorenen
pesto welchen die im prinzip ganz
normales pesto sind allerdings in 15
gramm hügelchen und damit kann man das
halt besser portionieren so nette idee
uns natürlich länger haltbar wenn steve
geboren ist ich bin mir jetzt mal dass
das gleiche festival braucht
immer schön aber
ich musste über feste und testet diese
supermarkt sofern auch großen
italienischen hersteller ja so ein
bisschen fertig schmecken aber das recht
zu kollecker und ich mag die idee dass
man das eingefroren hat daumen hoch
wir sind jetzt bei der feinkost
angekommen und alles bisher da es war
interessant aber ich glaube hier wird es
jetzt richtig lecker da werde ich doch
schon schwach
eine schöne espressomaschine und auch
ansonsten sieht es hier richtig gut aus
und wir suchen uns mal ein paar leckere
sachen
[Musik]
das passt dann eben guck mal da liegen
habe also ganze trüffel
hier ist richtig was los kostenlosen
trippe gibt es nicht was los so also das
sind hersteller von trüffel partie heißt
soviel wie keine ahnung
vom stopp bei mir drin ist einfach so
ein ganzes stück parmesan
so richtig viel trüffel zumindest
richtig viele dunkle es riecht unfassbar
troika also richtig krass wird richtig
dass für einen krieg das oder das klingt
diesen daumen was ist das denn hier
müssen halt probieren
viel probiert noch nie bier getrunken
deshalb probiere ich das jetzt einfach
mal fragen wie viel man pro person
bestellen kann hallo wir haben noch nie
hier getrunken
wir müssen trotzdem bringt probieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sind dass hier leute ist eine ganze
flasche espresso klingt komplett falsch
wenn man attraktiv ist er ich liebe
kaffee espresso und man macht einfach ja
pius xii
wenn ihr unbedingt mal wissen wollen wie
nescafé gemacht nein also es war zwar ok
aber es war ein bisschen wie so ein
abgepackter supermarkt kaffee und die
können auch lecker sein aber es ist halt
nicht das krasse weißt du es
als durchschnitt
also freunde trüffel perlen mit weißem
balsamico verrückt erstmal informiert
ist doch schon zum starker trüffel
geschmack dadurch oder prüfe gar nicht
stark
also es wird sehr sehr interessant das
hat schmeckt fast so ein bisschen wie so
ein leckeres salatdressing mit einer
truppe note und die textur ist wie
kaviar die erste tun
[Musik]
trüffel kugeln kriegen von mir einen
daumen zur seite weil an sich nicht geil
hat aber sehr viel raum für neues und es
ist halt geil so ich kann mir das übels
gut vorstellen so eine sterneküche oder
so und genauso zum kaufen für zu hause
also wir haben hier zweierlei einmal
back haben wir doch einmal cheesecake
bolt ja nicht probiert den donuts
da ist ja oberflächen vergessen dass
mehr panade ist nach dem bremer aber ich
bin auf den ski skateboard gespannt
gewartet und der war schon sehr wird zu
gerne von sap sanierte süße cheesecake
bolz habe ich so noch nie gesehen
das ist echt neu
ja geil kann heraus müsse
noch mehr als in dorn hat
[Musik]
eine sache die wir heute festgestellt
haben es ist ein wahnsinniger zulauf bei
ersatzprodukte vegetarisch vegan man
sieht ein stand wo sie vegetarisches
fleisch gibt und ein bus normales
fleisch geht und der eine ist voll der
anderes leer und wir haben heute etwas
gefunden veganen mozzarella ich bin sehr
gespannt wie das schmeckt wir haben
gerade eben auch kemmer noch normalen
probierte sein weil wir den perfekten
vergleich befragung probieren gibt also
es ist tatsächlich ist es quasi noch ein
prototyp oder also noch hinter
entwicklung weil die entwicklungszeit
unserem artikel uns einfach ein paar
monate er sehr interessant genau nach
solchen sachen sind wir nämlich auf der
suche
sind sie die erste marke die so was auf
den markt bringt wir sind bei mozzarella
kugeln auf jeden fahrer erste ich muss
probieren jetzt endlich mal
also die textur ist wahrscheinlich das
was noch optimiert wird ja wichtig aber
geschmacklich ist es auch schön mild
cremig aber es hat noch nicht diese
wieder diesen widerstand den bisher ja
das ist was ich kann sagt auch
hähnchenfleisch strukturen zu fehlt nun
ist auch in diesen herausrücken
eins zu eins etablieren und kanada an
den start geht so ein bisschen hin so in
so einen leichten mehligen bereich aber
ich finde trotzdem könnte ersatz absolut
legitim und sehr lecker also ich finde
es normal dass das so ein mutiges
produkt ist dass sie das auch
präsentieren bevor es entwickelt ist man
muss schon sagen wenn man da reinbeißen
mozzarella erwartet wird man
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen enttäuscht
aber wenn die sich weiterentwickelt
geschmacklich sind sie auf einem sehr
guten weg von der textur auch nicht so
sehr aber ich finds geil dass dies mal
daumen
so wie sie jetzt angekommen bei einem
stand ihr seht dass hier mit kleinen
portionen und die kommen aus dem 3d
drucker das heißt alles was wir sehen
ist 3d gedruckt und die haben ja gerade
eben erklärt diese kleinen würfel zum
beispiel von diesem gemüse würfeln die
wert bekommt ein würfel ist eine karotte
ist eine rote beete und so sind franz
auszuschreiben carrotmob erst ich
schmecke das ist eine karotte ist dieser
kleine würfel
ripley karotten einigen respekt hat und
normal gesund und dazu noch so ein
bisschen
zu alt
schon nicht so geil wie aber das ist so
innovation nur zum zweck der innovation
so man macht was neues das ist cool aber
es nicht bringt nicht so viel das ding
ist ich kann sich nicht überprüfen
natürlich gesagt man verliert nicht von
terminen nährstoffen planer war war sie
werden mit fünf würfe und seinen
gemüsebeete abdecken kann als das cool
aber ich bezweifle ich kann es auch
nicht beurteilen
eine weitere sache die wir austesten
cero nix sagt man das so genau erinnern
sich an alten youtube kollegen familie
das ist vielleicht seht ihr das video
sogar und das ist honig ohne zucker und
begann schmeckt er dann noch süßlich
wert darauf
seine band you stop geschmack das finde
ich interessant wie lavendel honig so
ein bisschen bin also eine leicht
lavendel note aber will kommt in die
süße nicht von sich behaupten
wir in der konsistenz her nicht ganz so
flüssig wie honig mehr aber trotzdem
super und handel probier doch mal
braucht muss bei den standard hat man
wirklich gemerkt dass die noch ganz
jungen sind und alles selbst mal das war
die produktentwickler sind und die
geschäftsführerin und alle die mit uns
stand und dafür war nicht super gut also
es ist dass honig ähnlichsten nicht
honig produkt was hier hatte das war
jetzt aber auch der letzte stand leute
wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal ordnung ist
das mal sortieren weil das man so viele
eindrücke zehn kilometer herumgelaufen
und wir sehen uns gleich wieder das war
es dann auch vom video leute ich muss
wirklich sagen es war sehr eindrucksvoll
keine frage aber es war jetzt kein
gourmet hat sage ich mal also man musste
wirklich suchen nach innovation auch und
nicht alles war super lecker
nichtsdestotrotz kann ich zwar ein sehr
interessanter einblick hinter die
kulissen der lebensmittelwirtschaft der
gastroszene und der supermarkt
lieferanten also dabei wirklich alles
vertreten dort hat genauso viel spaß wie
ich es war ein anstrengender tag aber
für mich als hätte ich ein bisschen mehr
gelernt über die kunst des
nächsten wieder wieder was gut ist ein